في العراق اذا ماتوا لنا كثيره وحلول
قليله وربما معدومه وتشكيل الحكومه
الجديده برئاسه محمد الشياع السوداني لم
يحل الكثير من الامور الخلافات باتت الان
بين كتل الاطار التنسيقيه الموالي لايران
بعض المناصب لا تزالوا شاغره ومنها رئاسه
جهاز الاستخبارات منصب مهم لايران بالطبع
والخلافه هنا بين مليشيا العصائب وحركه
حقوق الجناح السياسي للشيخ حزب الله
تنفيذ بنود الاتفاق السياسي خلاف اخر وهذه
المره تحاول اطراف داخل قوى الاطار عقله
الجنود الخاصه بمطالب القوى السنيه وخصوصا
تلك المتعلقه بالسحب الفصائل من المناطق
التي كانت تحت سيطره داعش اتفاقته سنجائر
المواقع بين بغداد واربيل
على ورق حتى الان خلاف ثالث ودوره ايران
هناك
سهرانه تتدخل في شؤون جيرانها وتطلب عدم
تدخلي في شؤونها الاحتجاجات تعم شوارع
ايران الفصائل المسلحه التابعه لها لن
تتخلى بسهوله عن سنجار باعتبار المدينه
وسيله ضغط على واشنطن وبغداد واقليم
كردستان
السلطات الايرانيه لا تريد ان تتاثر
سياستها التوسعي في العراق وفي هذه
الاوضاع خصوصا وانها لديها جبهه داخليه
الاحتجاجات ومن هنا جاءت زياره السوداني
لطيران خلال العقدين الاخيرين اعتاد
الطيران على دعوتي رؤساء الحكومات
لزيارتها بعد منحها الثقه من قبل البرلمان
لكن توقيت تلبيه الدعوه يخضع لعده اعتبارا
السياسيه وزياره السوداني جاءت سريعه
وتحديدا بعد اسبوع من زياره قائد فيلق
القدس في الحرس الثوري للعراق والذي قاد
تحالفات تشكيل حكومه السوداني
ده التوترات على الحدود مع كردستان العراق
احراج داخلي وخارجي للحكومه العراقيه لكن
الاعتبارات السياسيه ليست بعيده عن
الاقتصاد طبعا تعتبروا الطيران الجغرافيا
الاقتصاديه العراقيه مكمله لتثبيت نفوذها
السياسي تريد زياده منافذ التصدير ليصل
التبادل التجاري الى 20 مليار دولار
اقتصاد طيران متدهور وتريد الحلول والعراق
غنيم طبعا لكنه من هو لكن اللافت قله
الاتفاقات المواقعاه هو تاسيس مكتب
تمثيليه لوزاره النقل الايرانيه في العراق
والعهده على وكاله مهر الايرانيه
خطوه سياسيه بامتياز تتجاوز الرغبه بتطوير
التعاون في النفط والغاز النحو السيطره
على القطاع والتعاقدتين لملاوه العراق من
النفط الخام فقط خلال العام الجاري بلغت
نحو مئه مليار دولار سيطره وهيمنه
واستفاده اقتصاديه نعم لكنها ايضا ورقه
ضغطا سياسيه ثانيه بجانبه التي تحدثنا
عنها قبل قليل وهذه المره على الدول
الاوروبيه المتاثره بنقص الطاقه نتيجه
الحرب الاوكرانيه وايضا على الولايات
المتحده
[موسيقى]